joining us we begin with breaking news
out of Iraq where there's been a
Stampede in the southern city of Basra
we understand it took place at the Palm
trunk Stadium ahead of the final of the
Arabian golf cup there there are reports
of dozens of people injured let's bring
in Mahmoud abdelwahat who's on the line
from Basra Mahmoud what's happened
willfully we have been getting the
reports from the interior Ministries by
confirming to that and about 80 others
injured in a stampede that started this
morning around the Palmer trunk Stadium
here in Basra one of the stadiums
allocated for the matches of the Arabian
golf cup 25th edition as you know that
according to the Iraqi Football
Federation about 90 percent of the
tickets were already sold on a line
ahead of the ahead of that has made many
many football mad fans especially Iraqis
as you know that those who have come
from several provinces across Iraq they
have been traveling for long hours to
reach Basra to attend to say to see the
the matches in the studio in the stadium
to see their heroes in action in the
stadium that has admit many of them try
to reach to the stadiums as much as they
can as you know that tens of thousands
of fans from other countries especially
from Gulf Estates have been coming to
Basra and that has already put more
pressure on the already stretched
infrastructure in the city as you know
this is the first time the city has such
a tournament and that all that's also
after uh uh more than four Decades of
isolation and sanctions on Iraq that has
prevented the the country from hosting
any uh supported the activities so we
are seeing some photographic pictures
I'm sorry I just have to apologize to
our viewers who may be sensitive to some
of the pictures we're seeing right now
they are very graphic these are the
latest pictures we're getting out of
Basra where again if you're just joining
us there's been a stampede outside of
the stadium that International Stadium
which is about to host the final of the
Arabian golf cup at least two people are
reported killed dozens have been injured
Mahmoud Abdel wahad is on the phone uh
with us Mahmoud as you've said this is
golf cup it was the first major
tournament to be held in Iraq in 40
years and there was a lot of concerns
about challenges for the Iraqi
authorities you know now that we see
such an event happening there are going
to be questions raised about the
organization and and the Authority's
ability to host such a big tournament
exactly the authorities are not hiding
it I mean they say they say we are lucky
that we're hosting this special event
but the city is not as fully prepared as
it should be they they they admit that
the city uh there's a lot of work needs
to be done for the city to be fully
prepared for uh such an event uh you
know that Basra has been suffering uh
from uh several odds over the past
decades including uh a lack of services
uh security vacuum and it has missed a
lot of conflict even recently uh the
fact that it is also away from the
central government in Baghdad uh
probably has made it far from uh any
Improvement in development uh plans you
know that despite the fact that Basra is
a rich city it has about uh 70 percent
of Iraq's oil but yet it is still
suffering it is still a
partly marginalized and this event
despite the fact that it ends
to some extent the isolation the city
and the country has been suffering from
from three years but also it is an
opening with the gulf countries as the
Basra people here say and hope the
hopeful that this tournament is
reuniting Basra and Iraq with the other
Gulf Estates but again you know that
only two stadiums have been prepared for
the tournament the Boswell stadium that
can accommodate about 65
000 fans the other is the port Olympic
stadium and with capacity of about 30
000 fans you know this is only the the
capacity of the scene this is only what
the city can offer for this tournament a
tragedy there in southern Iraq in Basra
Mahmoud abdul-wahat thank you very much
for the latest there we will of course
be checking in with you throughout the
day for the latest on this story at
least two people dead in a Stampede in
Southern Iraq in the city of Basra
outside the international Stadium there
which was about to host the final of the
2023 golf cup which was the first major
football tournament to be held in Iraq
in 40 years we'll have the latest for
you on Al Jazeera throughout the day
let's move on